welcome to another one of my dr sailor
chalk and talk video lectures
devoted to
showing that you can in fact
inform people teach
get people excited through the
old-fashioned techniques of talking at
them and writing things on a blackboard
it's called truck and talk a little bit
in jest
you notice today i'm not dressed in my
normal
more
formal apparel i like to honor the
hallow tradition of casual friday and
this is also kind of an important day
for me
in part because this is is actually my
last day teaching a staple class here at
fayetteville state university
which i have been
very much consumed with over the last
three years critical thinking
i'm leaving fayetteville state
university and essentially starting a
new
and broader career
over the next several years in some
still some teaching writing talking
and
consulting
so
i'm not particularly dressed up but that
shouldn't affect the
content of the lecture
what are we talking about today
well
i've put it like this why
does leibniz remain in descartes chat
and i received a question
this time not through vu or youtube but
actually through email
and somebody asked i would like to ask
whether there is any reasonable
explanation
why many of uh today's philosophers or
philosophers in the last several
centuries
referred to descartes instead of
referring to livenets
although descartes had influenced
significantly into the new modern era in
philosophical thinking so did livenets
moreover leibniz proved some
imperfections in descartes metaphysics i
mean both of them deserve our attention
yet in my opinion limits is somehow
still indicative shadow why is that
that's a good question
i am actually quite sympathetic to the
notion
that if we
sort of put them toe-to-toe
and compare them side by side
that live with certainly merits just as
much honor
and
study as does descartes and that's
actually that's holding him very high
because
i think very
very strongly that descartes is one of
the key philosophers that you want to
read
probably not just the discourse but also
the meditations i go back every year
whether i teach descartes or not and i
read through the meditations
in english in french and in the latin
that descartes wrote them because i
consider it such as a seminal work
i also go back and i read some of the
live business works every year
including his
discourse on metaphysics which i also
think is a brilliant
and seminal
work
and it's well worth pursuing so
in order to answer this
you have to put yourself in the
perspective
of
the history of ideas
if you think about
the whole notion of the modern era what
are we talking about
we're talking about the notion that
there was a time before modernity
and interesting things happened
people
you know grew people changed
civilizations developed people came up
with ideas
great philosophers
wrote things down other philosophers
transmitted them
and studied them and commented on them
but then something changes in this new
modern period what makes this modern
period
actually
modern what
makes it distinctively new
well i mean part of it is newer
technology um you know spreads of
cultures the whole mechanism that we
nowadays call early globalization but
part of it
is in the realm of ideas in the realm of
intellectual culture and these
guys they all have a role in that and
they're all more or less contemporaries
descartes
is influenced by galileo and his early
work actually
which he suppressed when galileo
was persecuted
descartes knew of galileo's work he took
some ideas from him
thomas hobbes is also very influenced by
that uh hobbs is doing something kind of
similar to what descartes is doing in
epistemology
in terms of political theory but also
actually in terms of epistemology or the
theory of knowledge as well
pierre gascendy
known
in physics for some of his contributions
also was an important philosopher an
epicurean
trying to revive this tradition of
trying to explain things primarily on
their physical basis
that's something that these guys all had
in common descartes
arguably a little less so but descartes
also thought that the physical world
and insofar as it was extended matter
extended things extended substance
could be wholly explained by
mathematics and physics
they're reacting against scholasticism
and there's a sort of standard narrative
that holds that medieval philosophy had
become more abundant that it becomes
sterile they talk about angel how many
angels could dance on the head of a pen
in reality if you actually study
scholastic philosophy you find that
they're not concerned with that sort of
thing
they're much more concerned with with
real issues but they had a very
different approach
part of the approach was to
see what other people in the past had to
think about things before you open your
own mouth and try to show everybody how
clever you are right
that's something that that you might say
disappears in the modern era
the early modern era
is a time of
starting a new world at least appearing
to start again
i mean as we know from auntie and jose
descartes owes a lot to the
scholasticism that he's reacting against
so does thomas hobbes
but they are doing something
distinctively new
they are importing a new method
and descartes is bringing something
that i think you can't find in any of
these others with his notion of
hyperbolic doubt and sort of
wiping everything away and building
things from the ground up you might say
that hops is doing something similar at
least on political bases but descartes
is clearly doing that clearly
and
so they're going to get a lot of
credit um in the history of ideas for
doing something new particularly from
those later on the vantage point who
look back and don't actually know
anything about the scholastics you have
to remember that in the
in the 17th 18th 19th century unless you
actually were within the scholastic
tradition you probably did not read much
scholastic philosophy so if somebody
said hey those scholastic philosophers
they're no good they're just you know
jingling with words as hobbs said
then you're probably going to believe
them um particularly you know there are
some religious things mixed in as well
particularly if those those scholastics
are mostly catholics and you happen to
be say a calvinist right
but you know even within within catholic
france
you have people like descartes reacting
against these monastics and saying that
that stuff is no good
um
you have these post cartesian
philosophers
you know they're working within
descartes
wake you might say descartes has
changed the way changed the
the rules of the game
for how what's considered to be serious
philosophy is going to take place
and so people like benedict spinoza
clearly cartesian he actually writes a
book principles of cartesian philosophy
nicholas mall brush is adapting a cart
within an augustinian context
antoine or no who lived in its
corresponds with was was not a great
philosopher was one of those sort of
heavy hitters of the time
and then they have this guy
going free villain alignments a german
not a french guy
uh well
it's not french either but
and
he is coming in and
he actually arrives on the scene he's
not just concerned with doing philosophy
he's actually concerned with what we
would nowadays
uh
to some degree called geopolitics
he's also deeply concerned with theology
whereas descartes wanted to you know
wipe things away so you could rebuild
the basis of knowledge
one of leibniz's key ideas was he wanted
to bring the churches that had broken
apart in the reformation back together
by establishing a common philosophy that
they could all agree upon
somewhat of a kickstarter but a very
noble task
now all of these guys are working within
the cartesian tradition
leibniz is doing something new in that
he is bringing back
some elements of scholasticism
into cartesian philosophy you know the
notion for example of substantial forms
this is an idea that the cartesians had
rejected because they wanted to explain
everything in terms of just pure
extension and the relations between the
bits of matter
and lyman said no not even matter itself
has to be treated in a much more organic
manner
where the form of it
the intelligibility of it
means something important
well
what happens after that
you notice i also put blaise pascal in
there he's kind of a straddling figure
he's critical of the cartesians he's not
a cartesian but he's within this current
uh who are interested in a new way of
doing things
and he enlivens they actually have some
some important themes in common
with uh half activity and things like
that
what happens afterwards
i mean we have something going on in
britain of course there's a whole
empiricist tradition but i'm ignoring
that
we have conscious philosophy
interestingly leibniz was one of the
first people to write philosophy in
german he deliberately towards the end
of his life
wrote a few philosophical texts in
german most of the time he was writing
in french
or or in latin but he writes in german
to try to promote it as a language fit
for philosophy
and kant
very much does that i mean there's some
good things that khan did one of them is
to bring
german into sort of a
elevated status as a legitimately
philosophical language a fit tool for
doing that
and then you have all these other people
who come along and they are much more
interested when they're looking back
they're not so interested in these guys
they're interested in
these guys the the beginning of
modernity the radical shift khan
conceives of himself as doing a yet even
more radical shift he calls it his you
know copernican term and he finds ways
to put all these guys into perspective
it's a flawed perspective but it's one
that's very common
and i think that you see something
similar in the other
post-conscient philosophers
in germany and even to some degree
in france they're much more looking to
descartes is the central figure than
that would be the lions so
it's really because of the structure of
the narrative because of what we might
call dramatic positions because if you
look at his achievements
leiden has certainly achieved uh as much
if not more than descartes did and made
contributions
in more fields of human knowledge he at
one time was considered the universal
genius of europe
but you're right he has become somewhat
eclipsed in our time and that is because
he was eclipsed throughout a good
portion of modernity
this gets transmitted through through
sort of standard fair histories of
philosophy
uh textbooks through people who are not
really delving into these these
philosophical thinkers and studying them
on their own on their own grounds on
their own merits spending you know a lot
of time going back to the primary texts
but relying on
master narratives
and in those master narratives
the nade heart is simply more of a
central figure than northridge bill of
alignment says
so
there is my answer for you